well it's happening rod Rosenstein the
Deputy Attorney General is departing and
I hope that people are ready to hit the
streets in protest and I'll talk about
that in a moment here is what transpired
over the last three days a blockbuster
New York Times article claimed that
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
discussed the potential to remove Donald
Trump from office by using the 25th
amendment which is meant to enable the
removal of presidents who are unfit to
serve and also possibly mentioned the
idea of secretly recording Donald Trump
this is a hugely important story but it
seemed from the from the first moment
that it went out that it was possibly a
deliberately leaked story in order to
justify firing or forcing rod Rosenstein
to resign and that indeed is what
appears to have happened the New York
Times put this piece out they said
listen last year in 2017
Deputy Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
suggested that maybe secret recordings
should be made of Donald Trump suggested
the possibility of trying to convince
cabinet members of Trump's to invoke the
25th amendment to trigger his removal
from office on the basis of being unfit
to serve this supposedly all happened
during that insane period when we
learned that Donald Trump had fired FBI
director James Comey had pledged in
order to impede the investigation had
told James Comey that he wanted him to
pledge loyalty to Trump gave away
classified information to a Russian spy
recruiter in the Oval Office it was that
crazy time when all of that news was
breaking Rosenstein at the time had been
deputy AG for two weeks he was
overseeing the Russia probe because Jeff
Sessions was recused and he felt that
the memo he wrote justifying legally the
firing of James Comey was completely
misused by Donald Trump in justifying
the sort of underlying political
reasoning for the firing the New York
Times appears to have multiple sources
on the story and then we get into the
thick of it which is that Rosenstein
when the story went live when the story
was published by the New York Times
Rosenstein denied the account and then
it very quickly started to become
evident that this could be a story
number one used to justify the firing of
rod Rosenstein and number two may have
been leaked by the Trump administration
itself because of course I don't deny
for a second that the New York Times had
the sources they claimed to have but of
course we don't know exactly who those
sources are the Justice Department did
acknowledge that Rosenstein mentioned
the possibility of secretly recording
Trump but they said that it wasn't a
serious suggestion so first and foremost
we now have learned that indeed
Rosenstein is going this all broke in
the last 30 to 45 minutes or so before
we tape the show we don't yet know where
the Rosenstein is choosing to resign
because he feels that the story has made
him a big distraction
we don't know if Rosenstein was forced
to resign and we don't know if this is
straight up one of those firings which
is dressed up as a resignation which is
basically hey rod were firing you we
need you to submit your resignation at
this time but we have to be really
careful about the story because the
discussion around the story has been
basically a false dichotomy one
possibility is the story is real period
the other possibility is the story is
fake and planted by trumpets wanting to
justify Rosenstein s resignation or
firing it doesn't have to be just those
two possibilities it is a very real
possibility that the content of the New
York Times story is accurate but that
the timing of its leak to the New York
Times was there in order to create a
pretext for Donald Trump to fire rod
Rosenstein something that we know he is
increasingly eager to do and I think
that that is the most likely scenario at
this time it has become abundantly clear
that trumps desire to get rid of
Rosenstein as a sort of way to impede
the Russia investigation has become a
very high priority of Donald Trump's and
yet it still seems realistic that the
content of the story may be true
and now indeed Rosenstein is going
depending on whether it is a resignation
or a firing it's not consequential in
the sense that either way Rosenstein is
gone it is consequential
in terms of whether Trump can appoint an
interim person to fill in I'm sorry in
terms that that's not right strike that
it's important in terms of whether the
Solicitor General automatically becomes
the person supervising the Trump Russia
investigation or whether there needs to
be a trump appointed and Senate
confirmed replacement for Rod Rosenstein
so it is consequential whether it's a
firing or a resignation it does appear
that that New York Times story was a
pretext deliberately put out there in
order to justify Rosenstein firing and
number three the most important question
is will this succeed in order to impede
the investigation
I'm guessing Pat that they are not at
this point so audacious that they would
have whoever replaces Rosenstein
literally shut down the investigation
I think Muller would go nuts I think
that there would be hopefully a rise in
civil disobedience and protesting
although we'll talk about that later
the smarter way to do it is to just
impede the progress of the investigation
in other ways rejecting requests for
certain information getting in the way
of Trump ultimately sitting down with
Muller that would be the smart way to
impede the investigation yeah and this
is pretty major but maybe it doesn't
come across as much of a bombshell as
like the James Comey firing did because
there are so many layers here and we're
not even certain about all the specifics
in terms like there was a lot of lead-up
to it so I I'm worried that it would
cause progressives not to up rise and
actually take to the streets in anger
over what happened here because it just
kind of seemed like a foregone
conclusion you know what I mean in other
words Trump fires FBI director
specifically to impede the investigation
that has a different cachet that deputy
AG chooses to resign even if that's not
actually
what he did simply is not going to have
and it's not gonna rile people up in the
same way even though this is the easiest
path to ending the Russia investigation
because his replacement could do that
and the whole thing wraps up next thing
I want to talk about because we are
getting to it and the rod Rosenstein
departure whether it was a firing or a
resignation relates to that is that it
is time for people to get out in the
streets and that's what I want to talk
about next today's program is sponsored
in part by purple mattress did you spend
the night tossing turning is stress
keeping you up or maybe a stiff neck if
you're struggling to get a good night's
sleep you've got to try purple mattress
which is made with a brand new material
that was developed by an actual rocket
scientist
the purple mattress will feel different
than anything you've experienced unlike
traditional memory foam the purple
material is both firm and soft so it's
supportive yet comfortable and it's
breathable so it sleeps cool and with
their 100 night risk-free trial if
you're not fully satisfied you can
return your mattress for a full refund
not to mention it's backed by a 10-year
warranty with free shipping and free
returns you're going to love purple and
as of right now our listeners and
viewers will get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress in
addition to the great free gifts that
they are offering site-wide just go to
purple com use my promo code Pakman at
checkout that's purple comm code PA que
ma n the only way to get the free pillow
is to use my code Pakman at checkout
that's purple comm code
PA que ma N